[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
une émission pour vous présenter les
projets culturels yvelinois au programme
aujourd'hui le théâtre coluche de
plaisir présenter vienne 1913 en avant
première une représentation de fin de
résidence présenté par la compagnie
influent en scène un spectacle qui
revient sur l'histoire d'adolphe hitler
lors de son passage à vienne
sara jade était en résidence à la
batterie de guyancourt l'occasion de
travailler sur ses anciens morceaux et
réalisé quatre nouveaux titres objectif
enregistrer une captation du spectacle à
destination des professionnels
et puis side of joy le choeur gospel va
se rassembler pour la première fois sur
scène depuis janvier 2020
composée d'une trentaine de choristes le
coeur présentera 17 titres tels que
rapide et ou encore à let my people go
et je vous le disais en titre le théâtre
coluche de plaisir présenter vienne 1913
en avant-première c'était ce mardi 25
mai cette représentation de fin de
résidence destinée aux professionnels
était présentée par la compagnie
influent en scène un spectacle qui
revient sur l'histoire had adolf hitler
lors de son passage à vienne
les images de mélanie poké vienne 1913
un spectacle présenté par la compagnie
influent en scène mardi 25 mai au
théâtre
coluche à plaisir une pièce qui raconte
les quatre années d'adolphe hitler à
vienne prémices d'un bran antisémite qui
a toute la culture dans la ville
viennoise il y as en émergence en
prémice donc le pire qui va naître ce
furent l'antisémitisme le plus d'écart a
déjà les yeux
la pièce se joue dans un décor de
kiosque à musique sur scène neuf
comédiens interprètent un total de 23
personnages différents parmi lesquels
adolf hitler
la pièce s'ouvre sur le jour de ses 20
ans le 20 avril 1909 il vient de se
faire refuser à l'académie de vienne là
la difficulté c'est qu'effectivement il
faut laisser entrevoir le führer qui va
arriver
il y pas encore là il est encore jeune
il est encore idéaliste d'une certaine
manière j'ai travaillé un personnage qui
est assez froid statique cif mais
néanmoins très précieux dans la manière
dont qu'il a de s'exprimer je ne suis
pas content tu
aubade à corte pour mon vote alors comme
ça tu dessines des bâtiments pas
seulement
j'étudie wagner aussi prochain
rendez-vous proposé par le théâtre
coluche pixels le spectacle de danse hip
hop aura lieu le 11 juin à 20h30
c'est un une des plus belles
chorégraphies de mourad merzouki que
j'ai pu voir
moi je connais tous ses spectacles à
chaque fois je dirais pour chacun de ses
spectacles sim plus beau mais celui là
il me tient à coeur parce que si c'est
celui par lequel j'ai découvert ce
chorégraphe et c'était tellement
fascinant tellement merveilleux que j'ai
hâte de le présenter au public de
plaisir une cinquantaine de
professionnels du spectacle étaient
présents à l'avant première
la représentation à destination du
public est programmée au 15 octobre
à noter que le théâtre de plaisir change
de nom un changement voté ce mercredi 26
mai lors du conseil municipal de la
ville le théâtre espace coluche
s'appelle donc désormais théâtre coluche
et parmi elles les autres spectacles à
venir dans les yvelines le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous propose
de découvrir gong une comédie musicale
pop et coloré une création présentée le
vendredi 4 juin à 19 heures par le
groupe catastrophe
ça se passera à la scène nationale de
guyancourt sur scène six artistes
interroge notre rapport au temps qui
passe bougival ville des
impressionnistes un circuit en zodiac
est proposée par le nautic parc une base
nautique située en bord de seine pour
découvrir ou redécouvrir les grands noms
des impressionnistes lci agathe song au
bon soin ramon soir vous êtes avec nous
alors c'est une balade de deux heures
qui aura lieu ces deux prochains
week-ends oui samedi 5 et dimanche 13
juin prochain vous pourrez embarquer à
bord d'un zodiac un bateau pneumatique
qui vous permettra de découvrir le
berceau des impressionnistes sur l'île
de l'âge
c'est onéreux noirs qui étaient présents
et puis une fois n'est pas coutume on
met à l'honneur
berthe morisot qui a non seulement vécu
à montréal mais c'est également
énormément de tableau et a été un peu le
le le le coordinateur une sorte de chef
de file de tous ce nouveau courant et
donc concrètement comment ça se passe
alors c'est une visite commentée sur la
scène avec cette escale de bougival h à
tous la particularité les visiteurs
s'installent dans des bateaux de 6
places l'ensemble forme une petite
flotte qui se regroupent au près dans
droit au singulier accompagné d'un guide
droit frappant bien évidemment la
grenouillère qui a été l'endroit magique
pour les animations en ile-de-france et
monet renoir ont passé énormément de
temps là bas est très souvent ils
étaient ensemble ils décident d ensemble
du même tableau
et au moment de de nos visites quand on
descend et qu'on fait escale à la
grenouillère par exemple on montre les
deux tableaux dans la côté de l'autre
vous pourrez aussi découvrir le pont de
bougival et ses écluses des explications
sur l'origine et le fonctionnement de
celles-ci seront proposées au cours de
ce circuit vous apercevrez également les
vestiges de la machine de miles la
machine de marly qui étaient les grosses
roues à aubes qui vont pouvoir avec le
mouvement de l'eau entraîner l'ol à
faire remonter jusqu'au château de
versailles
aujourd'hui on n'a bien évidemment que
des vestiges et des aspects mais c'est
un endroit assez magie et donc à qui
sont destinés ces balades en autodidacte
et bien alors c'est pour tout public un
même si les enfants seront peut-être
moins intéressés par les explications du
guide
en tout cas c'est la septième année que
les circuits des impressionnistes existe
et c'est souvent complet il faut donc
penser à réserver sur le site ww point
activité qui raynaud tic point fr il
reste encore des places disponibles
merci scellier agathe son goût d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir
journaliste pour tv 78 côté exposition à
présent le musée national port royal
et champ vous propose de découvrir
l'exposition portraits une installation
issu d'un projet départemental à d'arts
plastiques des portraits célèbres
détournés ou encore des autoportraits
réalisés par des élèves de primaire 300
classes ont participé au projet
l'exposition est à découvrir jusqu'au 6
juin
le monde magique de posy vous propose
également de découvrir framboise et le
coeur du soleil un spectacle poétique
musical est destiné aux enfants un conte
sur le thème de la nature l'objectif
montrer que la créativité est partout
autour de nous et que chaque enfant ait
créé son propre monde imaginaire
le spectacle aura lieu le samedi 5 juin
à 16 heures à la librairie le pavé du
canal de montigny le bretonneux et tout
de suite un extrait du spectacle
framboise et le coeur du soleil est
suivie d'un mot de l'artiste flamand qui
tenait à coeur du soleil
[Musique]
3h02 et c'est l'histoire en fait d'une
d'une petite fille qui rentre dans un
jardin avec des fleurs géantes et en
fait elle cherche le coeur du soleil le
coeur du soleil représente pour elle sa
créativité son monde imaginaire et grâce
à deux oiseaux perchés sur un arbre qui
sont présents ici avec moi qui seront
donc dans le spectacle elle va découvrir
que c'est elle qui crée son monde
imaginaire
le spectacle dure une vingtaine de
minutes il sera suivi d'une séance de
dédicaces réservation obligatoire sur le
site le monde magique de posy clap de
fin de résidence pour la chanteuse sara
jade à la batterie de guyancourt une
semaine de travail intense qui aboutit à
la captation vidéo d'un concert d'une
heure et demie l'occasion de travailler
sur ces morceaux bixente mais rien senti
steban s'est rendu sur place regarder
[Musique]
ouais
une captation vidéo à huis clos pour la
chanteuse sara jade l'occasion de
présenter son concert fruit de quatre
jours de travail en résidence à la
batterie de billancourt
ça nous a permis sur les deux premiers
jours de faire vraiment de la création
pure musical aussi la création lumières
et sons on a monté tout un spectacle qui
va durer à peu près à venir 15h30
en plus des musiques déjà présente dans
son ep sorti en février dernier et
retravaillés pour l'occasion
sara jade a créé quatre nouveaux moments
[Musique]
je les écris mais un petit moment déjà
j'avais jamais encore eu l'occasion de
la créer dans son intégralité mais si
une chanson qui a été écrite après les
attentats du bataclan assez intense
voilà beaucoup d'intensité
très rock très rentre dedans un peu
énervé ce qui était un petit peu mon
état d'esprit du moment quand j'ai écrit
ce morceau une heure et demie
d'enregistrement intense avec pour seul
bémol l'absence du public
aujourd'hui on a fait une captation
vidéo mais c'est vrai que le public nous
manque donc on a hâte de le retrouver
sur scène le but de la résidence est
vraiment de créer le spectacle dans son
intégralité avec le son la lumière les
nouveaux morceaux pour pouvoir ensuite
le présenter aux amateurs des salles de
spectacles
et puis pour pouvoir nous
nous produira sur scène dans plein
d'endroits les endroits qui voudront
bien de nous en attendant d'autres
rendez-vous sara jade et son groupe se
reproduiront à la batterie avec du
public cette fois le 12 juin prochain
[Musique]
seeds of joy le choeur gospel va se
rassembler pour la première fois sur
scène depuis janvier 2020 une trentaine
de choristes vous donne rendez vous le
samedi 12 juin à 20h30
la représentation aura lieu à l'église
de saint thibault opecst le coeur
présentera un répertoire un répertoire
varié au programme à 17 titres tels que
rapide et ou encore let my people go
la présidente de seeds of joy la chef de
choeur nous présente le concert à venir
vous pouvez vous attendre à un partage
parce que chez seeds of joy en aime
échanger avec le public on vous fera
peut-être même chanter n'hésitez pas à
vous lever à taper dans les mains il ya
bien des champs vous allez forcément
connaître il y en a que vous allez
découvrir
mais les champs comme garde de rôle
world et nissan soit là pour vous donner
une petite un petit échantillon
et puis à côté de ça on a des deschamps
plutôt des années 80 même des chants des
années 2000 parce que il faut savoir que
le gospel c'est un genre qui est
aujourd'hui encore composer et qui est
extrêmement vivant et c'est la fin de ce
numéro du 7-8 culture merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi est très belle soirée
et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]